this historic 2020 nba championship
belongs to the los
angeles lakers vanessa bryant is
celebrating the lakers championship
victory and remembering her late husband
kobe bryant nine months after his death
you guys come take the trophy
on sunday the los angeles lakers beat
the miami heat
106 to 90. and shortly after the big win
vanessa hit up her insta story to
commemorate the moment
posting a throwback pic of kobe and the
lakers general manager rob palinka
standing courtside she wrote quote go
lakers congratulations uncle p
congratulations lakers
kobe was right rp stay the course block
out the noise
the 38 year old added quote wish kobe
and gigi were here to see this
but that's not all the proud mama
reposted
this pic from disney's account that's
the magic castle lit
up in lakers purple and gold and this
post from the lakers account
tagging two of the team's stars lebron
james and anthony davis
she also reposted this video of anthony
talking about his
late friend after the game you know ever
since the tragic tragedy
you know all we want to do is do it for
him and we didn't let him down
and vanessa shared this pic of kobe and
gigi from 2009
writing in part quote national
father-daughter day
what i try to teach the girls not just
her but all the girls on the team is
it's a process you just work every day i
mean we only started playing about a
year ago
right so it's just chipping away at
things you just get better and better
the lakers win
marked the team's 17th championship
title in total
but this was their first championship
victory since 2010
when kobe and pal gasol led the team to
beat the boston
celtics and the team made sure to honor
his memory throughout the finals
they wore kobe inspired black mamba
uniforms
on game five on friday and lebron james
opened up about honoring the basketball
legend after the team secured their
place in the finals
late last month every time you put on
purple and gold
you think about his legacy you think
about him and what he meant to this
franchise for 20 plus years
and what he stood for both on the floor
and off the floor
what he demanded out of his teammates
what he demanded out of himself
the win comes after kobe and his 13 year
old daughter gianna
died in a helicopter crash along with
seven others in calabasas california in
january
following the series winning game lebron
reflected on how
kobe's death affected the team and
propelled them
through the season we got
as close as you possibly can be when
that moment happened
um and obviously we know it brought the
whole basketball world close
as well but when you're internal um and
it hits home
it just means that much more and we
locked in from that very moment
and saying this is um this is bigger
than us